es el último giro en el enfrentamiento
de elon musk con la prensa los
periodistas que habían sido suspendidos
de la plataforma después de que él les
acusará de violar la seguridad de su
familia Ya recuperaron sus cuentas tras
una encuesta quien mezclas en internet
el pueblo ha hablado ahora se levantará
la suspensión de las cuentas que
difundieron mi ubicación la suspensiones
se produjeron tras la decisión de más de
bloquear una cuenta que rastreaba los
vuelos de su avión privado utilizando
datos públicos Esto llevó a Twitter a
cambiar también su política sobre el uso
compartido de la ubicación varios de los
reporteros suspendidos habían estado
escribiendo sobre la nueva política de
la red social entre las cuentas que se
restablecerán figuran las de periodistas
del New York Times el Washington post y
CNN su suspensiones causaron alarma en
la ONU
las voces de los medios de comunicación
no deben ser silenciadas en una
plataforma que profesa hacer un espacio
para la libertad de expresión
desde nuestro punto de vista la medida
peligroso precedente en un momento en
que periodistas de todo el mundo se
enfrentan a la censura a amenazas
físicas e incluso a cosas peores
seguimos en contacto con los
responsables de Twitter
todo esto no es más que la última de Las
batallas contra la moderación de
contenidos y ahora también corre riesgo
de entrar en conflicto con algunos
medios de comunicación